okay the final problem the last episode
of Sherlock series for possibly the last
episode of Sherlock will ever get I mean
you know it's not out of the realm of
possibility but it certainly ends on a
note that feels like we need to end this
in a way that might be okay to be the
last thing we ever do so yeah if you saw
my earlier video talking about my
concerns about how euros was going to be
handled and some things that I were
afraid might happen well almost
everything I was afraid of did in fact
end up happening not quite all of it and
I'll start by covering the stuff that
works because I know much like when I
talked about the six actors once I get
into the stuff that I don't like it's
just going to get ranty and that's hard
to come back from so stuff that work I
actually liked how Moriarty was used and
that was one of the main things I was
worried about and I'm AI think they
managed to integrate Moriarty into the
episode in general and into euros the
story in particular without undermining
him they make it clear he always had his
own thing going on it's just that for
this last sort of post mortem thing that
he's torturing Sherlock would he is
involving somebody else and I'm okay
with that
so obviously he was starting to mess
with Sherlock before he ever met euros I
like the use of of this footage that he
had put together for her and left her
with and I want to say overall his use
is just really solid it's very good it's
very clever
they managed to close out his story
without undermining him which I was
pretty sure was going to happen that did
that was one of my fears that did not
come true oh I didn't mention their
spoilers coming though if you're still
sticking around he is and figure that
out yet yet sports so the best section
was the stretch of the thing where
Mycroft and Watson and Sherlock were on
that island after euros had taken over
the facility and she was just putting
them through tortures and games that was
the best segment and that felt well it
felt very Moriarty so it did feel a
little bit like a retread by thought
that that was the straw
his bid was the tensest it was it felt
the most character focus in a way that
wasn't stopping the story dead and that
is kind of it
most of the rest I've got problems with
but pretty much all circles around euros
now this thing dug itself a really big
hole early on and I never quite
completely pulled out of it and that is
what we find out about euros and sort of
how she operates and what she is about
what she does completely broke my
suspension of disbelief on two levels
first off this whole thing that Mike
Ross says others like anyone she talks
to she could manipulate can get them to
do what they want I'm sorry
it doesn't work it pushes this idea too
darn far basically they just gave her
super hypnosis she she is a supervillain
she has a super power in this and I mean
I know Sherlock has always kind of had
you know super intellect or whatever but
because he's just making deductions and
you get a breakdown eventually and how
he figured stuff out
it doesn't least seem like okay if my
brain could operate that fast maybe I
could still figure that out you look at
the same stuff everyone else does he's
just making the connections much faster
than most people what your office is
doing defies any sort of basis in
reality whatsoever in my mind there's
really only two ways you can do this
whole sort of
psychotic person who manipulates people
to do what they want either you do sort
of the Joker Dark Knight thing which was
more implied in that thing but where
they pull in and people with comparable
psychosis gravitate towards them and
find them magnetic and want to listen to
them and follow instructions that's
option one that works
option two if you want to show them
getting a more or less normal stable
person to do things that are completely
outside of what a normal stable person
should do then you've got to go the slow
burn we've got to see this person break
down that normal person and really mold
them into something that is believable
and they don't take the time
time to do that now things like the TV
show Hannibal did that really well it's
something like gone growth where they
take their time this the so much of the
plot hinges on the idea that just a few
minutes talking Georgie can control what
you can do and I'm sorry bull if they're
going to find a way to strictly limit it
like to just the director of the
facility that's one thing but she's
obviously got control of every single
person in there because the guards and
whatever are doing things that if they
were still in their right minds and the
director was just telling them to do
they would go no I'm not going to do
that you're obviously nuts now but they
didn't they did it anyway so the clear
implication is that euros is controlling
every single person in that facility
bull bull so there's thing number one
that broke my suspension of disbelief
with her the other thing that broke my
suspension of disbelief with her is the
level of exactly how psychotic she
appears to be because for what we've
already seen her do she has to be able
to hold it together actually pretty darn
well and from what we see by the end of
this episode she kind of can't she
actually has to yell at the guards to
pull her off of sure like to be sure
that she doesn't kill him before you
know the circumstances under which she
wants to do it if she's just left were
advices she's not going to be able to
stop herself from killing him and yet
going by what happened in the previous
episode in the lying detective where we
have to be able to swallow that she was
John's shrink from multiple sessions
held it together well enough that there
was no indication until she was ready to
show him that she was completely off her
rocker Plus spending a significant
amount of time right in front of
Sherlock while Sherlock was making
deductions think about that yes I know
he was whacked out of his mind on drugs
and I'm not expecting to recognize euro
but he was making deductions and they
were all accurate to the person she was
pretending to be so she had to be
together enough to gather everything she
needed about faith and about culverton
Smith and
all that thing and put it all together
so that Sherlock would make the
deductions that would lead him to the
conclusion that she wanted him to get to
while not giving any indications of
anything that would be in any way
despairing with the image that she's
trying to project
she is not together enough to pull this
off not the way that she is depicted in
this episode I will buy that she's
intellectually smart enough but she's
just she's not stable enough I mean for
crying out loud
every time she closes her eyes she's a
scared little girl on an airplane you're
telling me that woman was able to pull
all this off again
no bully and then the whole thing goes
for emotional weight at the end it
doesn't work because we've just met this
character and okay another thing that is
completely unnecessary find out that
Redbeard was in fact yet another home
sibling is totally unnecessary because
it's not suddenly like we go whoa she
really is act like we've been watching
her kill people already we know how
crazy she is the idea that she killed
her her brother does not up the crazy
factor we're already watching her
potentially have had the option and
might have been able and willing to kill
her siblings already up to this point so
that doesn't add anything to dimension
it's just needlessly cruel and I don't
mean cruel for the character I mean
cruel from the writers why would why why
there was nothing gained by having it be
another brother instead of a dog other
than to stretch credibility further on
Sherlock's entire self-imposed
rearranging of his memory because now he
rasili stretched that and now I think I
get why all the other series ended on
cliffhangers because the way this thing
ends it's just it's cheesy it's
painfully cheesy and like look I'm happy
that they you know rebuilt the apartment
and they're taking cases again great
that's wow that's what I want from them
but to really a slow motion and no
context run out of a door off they go on
another day my God how nineties TV movie
freeze-frame on the high five kind of BS
is that and let strong godless trad line
when the other cop says he's a great man
he goes no he's a good one of
Yeah right before he said I was elegant
don't say it don't say and he said my
god look like I said there are some
solid things here something I didn't
mention earlier my cross really good in
this Sherlock and Watson are fine and by
themselves but everything about euros
does not well almost anything the vast
majority of euros doesn't work because
they're asking us to swallow things that
don't fit into this universe I mean the
world of Troy I guess has been built is
not a 100% realistic universe I don't
need it to be 100% realistic universe
but the world that they built doesn't
allow for super hypno voice crazy girl
what I wish they'd done instead was just
had it be all Moriarty I mean you know
come up with some kind of high-level
henchmen to actually pull some logistics
but like I think back to the part that
worked the best when they were trapped
in that in that facility and we were
getting glimpses of Moriarty that could
have all just been recorded and they
could have all been set up by him and
they just had to battle the ghost of
Moriarty effectively one more time I
think that would have worked so much
better and we still would have gotten
what were the strongest parts of this
episode but euros just wrecks this whole
thing and I don't blame the actress I
think she plays it as well as it could
be played from a writing standpoint it
was a bad idea and it's not well
executed I honestly don't know if it
could have been executed all that much
better it's a bad idea I said that I
needed them to stick the landing on the
series and they really really really
didn't it's not the worst fall down and
quality for a finale I've ever seen you
can go on back and see my rant about the
series finale for Dexter you want to see
about something really failing on every
level so this is not that but this is a
big disappointment really for the ending
of the series potentially the ending of
the show
yeah but the line detective was still
great I stand by my review III didn't
talk about it before but the abominable
bride I really liked so the series for
half of it is really good but the other
half Wow
no no so those are my thoughts on the
final
and it was a problem they could not
solve have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe go ahead hit that Bell down
there so you get notifications when new
stuff goes up follow me on Twitter our
council of geeks check out the council
of geeks podcast available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned